quel impact du colis de 19 sur la
consommation de drogue
ça c'est la grosse question le coc vide
a eu un impact très important sur un
certain type de drogue en particulier
les drogues telles que la cocaïne ou
l'ecstasy qui se consomme dans des
contextes de convivialité forte où il ya
des interactions entre les individus et
donc pendant la période du confinement
les niveaux de consommation d'ecstasy et
de cocaïne ont considérablement baissé
dans le monde et en particulier en
france
un autre enseignement c'est que là il ya
eu très peu de pénurie en fait en termes
d'approvisionnement les trafiquants se
sont adaptés les dealers ont mis en
place donc des livraisons à domicile par
exemple pour le cannabis
on a vu également une augmentation de
l'auto culture ce qu'on a observé
également c'est une augmentation des
usages de produits psychoactifs a des
visées thérapeutiques pour calmer
l'anxiété l'angoissé liée au confinement
concernant l'alcool on a observé pendant
la période du confinement une
augmentation du nombre de jours où les
personnes ont pu consommer de l'alcool
mais on a observé une diminution des
ivresses donc est d usage d'alcool
problématique en population générale
[Musique]